hey everybody welcome to the Reuben
report i'm dave rubin and we've got two
great guests for you this week miss
Wendy Liebman and mr. Paul case and this
is YouTube so let's get right to it
obviously the big the big story of last
week and what's going to be the big
story for the next couple months is the
Boston Marathon terror attack and all
the fallout after that and we're going
to be dealing with trials and just a
whole mess of stuff but I wanted to
focus on the media angle here because
that in a weird way became a bigger
story than the actual attacks themselves
so CNN was the one that really took it
on the chin so to speak let's jump in
and watch a little bit of their coverage
but essentially told we have one person
in focus that's our focus right now
we're going to try to apprehend that
suspect that we they didn't see it
clearly identified we are now told
addresses been made because I shouldn't
say this on TV but this is a good time
when TV unfolds wait maybe faster so
there is a difference between the
identification which everyone can
confirm now right everyone to say it so
this may be look very different in about
an hour if we learned that there has
been no arrest but the good news is is
that least there's an identification of
an individual something can be taken
into custody without an arrest right so
this is all the terminology but i have
actually three separate sources but to
that are very highly placed in close to
the investigation that have just told me
that there has been no arrest and in
fact the suspect has not been identified
by name yet that they have they're
looking for someone but they don't have
anybody in custody yet and they don't
have
identification okay so we basically had
four days of that reporting one thing
and then finding out it wasn't true an
hour later or the big thing was we don't
want to speculate and now we will
speculate so my first question for you
guys is has the media just lost control
of breaking news altogether in an age of
Twitter can the media operate in the old
school way that we we think it used to
well didn't do we win the presidency one
year over Truman like remember when they
ran that newspaper he did at least for a
day in one paper right right i think
people are always rushing to have the
conclusion because we need answers
really quickly so maybe it's a game of
telephone and people get the wrong
information yeah does it seem worse now
though because of twitter because
everyone can do it it's not like a
newspaper is gonna run a story and
that's the only way we're gonna get it
look yeah we're all did the woman who
said I probably shouldn't say this on
television yeah automatically she was
like I'm just guessing and she also said
you know in two hours this might change
she basically said I don't really know
what I'm saying I'm just gonna stay it
just in case yeah so you know she is
rushing I said she looked so eager yeah
we didn't first we did the first me to
do first before somebody tweeted it or
before it was on Facebook or you know
right there's a you can see it on there
that's right and everyone else is just
on board for that yeah so partly it's
that they all want to be first but how
much of it do you think is just like
this endless ego running you know you
mean they're on TV they want to say
something and they want the clip that's
gonna then go viral right who broke the
story like it's just pure ego it seems a
good ego and advertising they want a
little bit tune in to their station so
that they can have better at when you
break it first then everyone's can trust
you more but I mean you're right it is
easygoing most people who tweet
shouldn't even be tweeting anyway
they're just it's all ego it's all
ego-driven who cares what you have to
say necessarily why do you have to make
that said what you have well I kill you
have to say to but my point is do
likewise idea that what you have to say
is is important or more important than
someone else yeah and that clip is an
example of that to you know it's like
it's just so fast for no
when really yeah just calm down a minute
well one of the things I kept thinking
is I was watching all the coverage is
how you know something horrific happened
and obviously deserved a lot of
attention but then immediately we forget
every other bit of news that we've been
talking about endlessly so for a week
North Korea didn't have nukes anymore
you know you mean the way the day before
that was 18 stories on Drudge we're
gonna get nuked and then for a week we
didn't hear about it so as part of the
problem that the news cycle just keeps
us in this constant state of fear and
wanting more information quick in China
one of the days where over 100 people
died and God yeah a little blip and
that's it well the good news is you can
just turn it off can you go yeah it
seems like it I did yeah and I followed
Twitter a little bit and I got bits and
pieces from trusted new sources you know
it's like depends who you follow too and
you know this to teach history don't you
sometimes sometimes so I mean it really
is like who do you believe right yeah is
there also a problem with you know I was
watching CNN and you know they're all
it's like you got wolf and he's so stiff
and then everybody has their little john
king seems a little drunk sometimes but
one of the things i was watching is
Anderson Anderson Cooper who's like the
darling of everything is there a problem
that he has a daytime talk show although
I guess since it's been cancelled but
it's not off the area she seems a little
bizarre to me but it's like he's talking
about snooki and all and honey boo boo
during the day and then and then at
night he's talking about this serious of
and it kind of seems a little ridiculous
does that seem legit kind of like me
being here talking like I know something
and then telling jokes about my hair
yeah at lappers good boy good boy Touche
there's two sides of that though too in
a way that there is something like why
should i you're talking about honey boo
boo what do you really know about this
but there's also something i think that
makes people comfortable that they're
like oh we know you because you talked
about honey boo boo earlier today what
else is he saying so it depends on the
viewer I suppose yeah well i scryed
source yeah i guess we want them to all
be better and not be so drunken you know
well that's the other thing you know
poor Jake Tapper they got him up at like
three in the morning and you know then
the guy has to be on air for six hours
and then we expect every word to come
out of his men
to be perfect see the one who did the
obscenities right away and got fired no
jenever I mean that was the local that
was the local story yeah if you guys
didn't hear about that there was a guy
in North Dakota on NBC affiliate who
literally the first two words out of his
mouth in his career on camera were
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] we can say we
can say it he said [ __ ] [ __ ] and they
fired him immediately although I was
watching TV well he was nervous do you
want me is trying to pronounce someone's
name and I think he got flustered like
he couldn't say and he was like [ __ ]
[ __ ] and the woman who was the co-anchor
was like and she's tried to talk and all
the sudden you could you see her give up
and she was a good but talk about how
about yourself getting fired on your
first day on the job cheri oteri when
she was on Saturday Night Live one of
her earlier appearances she said [ __ ]
and that got her all this attention I
don't know if she got fine it's so funny
because they find people in different
professions like in in sports but they
don't find us well and you know when
they find people for entertainment
purposes the guy I think I don't I know
nothing about sports so there was I
think it was a Red Sox game where
somebody this week said something about
like we're [ __ ] Boston Ecuador team
and they're not finding him be said
because they said his heart was with
Boston or something like that it's like
what well you make those rules from the
right place after this whole thing all
right well the point is CNN even if
you're the pH exactly even if your
coverage was [ __ ] [ __ ] nobody got
nobody said it on air and I guess that's
the important thing all right let's move
on let's talk about let's talk about
weed because I think after last week
everybody could use a little weed in the
country if there was ever a time that
America needed to take one sort of
massive bong game I think I think this
is it so a senior lecturer at Harvard
University jeffrey miron has added up
some numbers related to weed and
basically if we legalize we're going to
show you the graphic right now if we
legalized it would save us about 20
billion dollars a year that's be four
billion it would be about 8.7 billion
saved in law enforcement 8.7 generated
from taxes and then if you adjust for
inflation
and I don't think that's 20 million
bucks billion 20 billion did I just say
million yen because that's how crazy it
sounds it's crazy and W that's not even
including the revenue from tasty cakes
yeah exactly the people at hostos that
would solve that whole Twinkie thing
yeah i mean really netflix would prosper
i think people would be nicer I think
all wars would be cupcake I'm gonna be
calm down a little bit yeah they would
be fought over cupcakes or no no they
just eat cupcake it was your Seneca one
cares yeah is there any reason that weed
is not legalized I mean we see these
numbers all time I didn't know about the
20 billion number but we see this stuff
all the time and it just seems like why
are why are we not doing is or I guess
we sort of slowly all right down there I
mean for medical use in quotes yeah
what's the revenue on that though has
been significant enough to help prove
that point I don't know these things
yeah yeah I mean I think they in
Washington they don't know how much to
tax right right you're still figuring it
all out and yet I see it as I mean a
cash crop no pun intended but I do think
that we're gonna have to legalize it
soon because the tobacco crops are gonna
need a new crime we're gonna need a new
crop the rest people are getting wiser
right not because we're gonna make it
illegal but because people are buying
slowly weaning themselves off actually
because they realize right and they're
smoking the electronic cigarettes now
yeah I've heard an ad for today I
thought you weren't allowed to advertise
for cigarettes but I heard an ad for an
electronic cigarette you actually can't
advertise on television for regular
cigarettes but they're now letting you
know you can't okay and but they're
letting them advertise for these
electronic cigarettes which supposedly
have like eight times the car cg car
slowly it's really well no smoke though
so that's but no smoke exactly oh that
you can also advertise for the nicorette
gum yeah the little band that's
practicing on your dashboard all right
what's that like either for nikah red or
chantix or some canned x there's
something about that this seems to me
like this is definitely going in the
right
you know because it's sort of like it
seems like marriage equality to me where
the numbers just keep ticking in the
right way so is this this is just a
matter of time at this point do you
think I think so I mean I think in the
last episode of weeds they it was flash
forward into the future and we saw that
starbucks had bought out Nancy bow twins
home business and hey you never know I
read something about how they were
getting vending machines ready for to
sell weed to sell weed I always think
it's weird that like we never see bad
examples where ever we has been
legalized and you can obviously look at
Amsterdam as the number one thing I mean
the drug rates don't go up the city then
taxes it and they have beautiful streets
and cabs and nice parks and everyone
seems happier so where what is the fear
with weed what do you think the fear
really comes down to Nancy Reagan yeah
and just say no just say no yeah um I
don't know i mean it is an evolution i
suppose like marriage equality in that
when people are frantic about the
economy and most people not most people
i shouldn't say that people who are not
educated about what they're arguing
about when they start seeing numbers
that look good things make sense to them
and then they're willing to adjust a
little bit more so i think when people
see a number like 20 billion and then
you throw in some unemployment numbers
and this is shitty and that's better
people look for the better thing so it
kind of pushes it so you think it's good
that we're in the middle of a recession
or we're kind of getting out or it's
kind of getting worse depending on who
you list do but that you throw out a bit
number like 20 billion and then people
will be like oh sure is that we went on
the fence about because i think some
people don't give a [ __ ] about weed and
some people are very and then other
people are there's also him they can
write that can do loathing and right
it's an away from values yeah nothing to
do with THC I actually think part of the
reason that people are against weed
whoever is left that it's against is
that they you know we'd actually makes
you think a little bit you know any mean
it makes you think and the one thing the
government can't have citizens doing is
thinking they can't have us walking
around thinking right cuz what would
have you were just thinking all that
they'd all be comedians ever
thinking but we'd also be sleeping we do
I think sweeping well yeah I knew we'd
have things I mean no one no one gets
stoned and it's like let's go for a
joyride everyone's like let's just sit
here watch TV for a little bit so that
would not be good for the economy well
no be great for the economy because it
be it would take away from drunk driving
perhaps people were just gonna call
pizza dominos right we should have got
stoned before the segment really
dominant and really thought this thing
out all right well from weed let's move
on to star wars you know I've been doing
the show for about three months and I
haven't mentioned star wars yet which
considering it's pretty much everything
I believe in is hard to believe so
everybody knows disney bought the star
wars the rights to Star Wars the entire
expanded universe the whole thing from
George Lucas and starting in 2015
they're going to be making a film every
summer and it's going to be the trilogy
789 every other year with little one
character spin-offs after that and I'm
very excited about this but I have to
say part of me is a little sort of taken
back by that just everything this feels
so corporate what once was something so
special to me and he fought the system
and you know created something so
brilliant in this whole world and now
it's just Disney giant machine is this
just the way everything just ends up
being I have three things to say one my
husband started his writing film career
because he saw Star Wars and he was so
inspired secondly I don't know the
difference between Star Trek and Star
Wars centered is President Obama no I
mean I really do but I feel I don't I
could and the third is I once when I was
a little girl I watched a movie called
the long week at the Lost Weekend and in
the middle of the movie they came on and
they said we put the second reel on
first by accident and like I watched
this whole I mean it was unheard of all
right and they played the whole thing
again like they started from the
beginning that's how I feel with star
it's like I don't know did it start and
the first time like it's very confused
as I five-person it can be very
confusing what do you think well is this
just sad that everything just goes so
corporate and even that they've related
this way like for the next six years
every summer we're going to make you not
enough yeah and at the same time Disney
laid off like 150 people i worked at
lucasarts that was creating all the
video games for Star Wars okay first I
have never seen a single star wars movie
enough nothing so if you want me to stop
I will but we may not show now but now
he's not the Booker I will have to talk
to I agree with you though because I
knew that there were what three to begin
with and then they really like this is
the prequel and I was like oh cuz this
happened who what and that's why I'm not
really interested in it very much I
think also because I hadn't seen it when
I was young so I just didn't care okay
but you're a big it's I I mean every
almost everything i believe is built on
something from the Star Wars universe so
you know what let's take this a little
back from Star Wars up and focus on the
idea that can we do anything original
any more like that's a very big go ahead
it's like it in a way to me it seems
like something that is a cult classic
something that you enjoy and you're
clearly not alone it becomes more like
the scary movie franchise where it just
gets more ridiculous when it's like
scary movie 13 and you're like oh is
this part of the spin-off are they gonna
bring that character back to because
it's it's just almost like a joke after
a while yeah but the corporate end of it
that's the part that scares me that we
just keep instead of coming up with
original thought good cry you know
there's some kid that's 15 right now
writing some amazingly brilliant thing
right that'll probably never get
produced because the you know the
corporation's we'll just yeah you know
gone can we spin off Marvel and big
blockbuster right now when you go to I
mean you go to the movies or a while ok
so you don't rent it I dressed up for
revenge either descent I've never said
that ought to go yeah I've never said
that ass if I don't that was no sixth
and lord Lorrie Louise but it's friday
on tuesday yeah so is it just naive of
me am i just a wild thinker to believe
that maybe corporate America won't
infect every Gus though think about
Broadway there is no original thing on
Broadway it's all movies being adapted
for for the air and theme park in theme
park right yeah being adopted adapted
for the stage like they're you right
there's a kid somewhere who was a great
musical idea
that is never gonna be able to push it
through a window oh yeah I'm Steve
behind it so what is that about us why
is that we all if you were to ask
anybody they would say oh I want
something original I want something
fresh and Yabu you can identify with it
you've seen the little know what you
expect right right when my pen when I
lived in New York of my parents came to
visit they wanted to see something like
The Little Mermaid because they knew how
the story ended they knew what to look
for and what to wait for it I'm gonna
waste their money right yeah that was oh
maybe we're lazy we're lazy write it i
guess it's why people come to New York
City and go to the Olive Garden in time
right where's Lizzie you know where
they're lazy ah apple juice applebees
weld is the I will be still paying to go
Star Wars movies and I'm gonna drag
Wendy and Paul I'm not dressing up maybe
with a scare oh man who had that hair
come on Fisher Carrie Fisher who played
Princess Leia yeah yeah look at this all
right we did something ok Disney's gonna
make a lot of famous people out of the
new Star Wars franchise which is a
perfect segue to this so researchers in
Sydney looked at the age and cause of
death for a thousand people in the New
York Times obituaries between 2009 and
2011 and let's take a look at some of
this stuff the national average age of
death for 2010 was 78 points 7 years the
average age of death for performers and
athletes about a year and a half less
77.2 and the average age of death of
business people 83 years so they say
love what you do everybody says that
love what you do that is the key to
happiness but apparently not the key to
longevity does this scare your eyes to
me the business thing yeah aren't like
high-powered businessmen full of stress
and heart attack heart and they drink
generalize yeah of course but you know
pressure right yeah to perform so even
though they're not famous they're still
accountable yeah so i would think that
surprised me that number and again
they're just numbers that somebody is
showing me so I mean even though its
statistical i right i mean it's not
completely or not it's not a perfectly
scientific study because it's obituaries
that were in the New York Times which
you're probably is a probably certain
subset of people but we're all
performers we're all big stars do you
fear that you are cooking scary then do
you fear that you're gonna lose a couple
years off your life because of the crazy
lifestyle is I'm still alive right now
um I don't know I always thought if it's
in the cards that i'm gonna be extremely
rich and successful I hope I live to be
a hundred so I can just sit there and
enjoy it at a pool and drinking all day
yeah so we're people that are following
our dream to do what we want to do so
you think that that leads itself to a
healthy lifestyle that's what everyone
says if you're if you're living in the
moment and all that kind of stuff and
hopefully you have some money and you're
successful but you think that these
business people are just going to drop
dead because they're not happy and yet
we're finally out it's the complete
reverse of it when they're working I
mean sometimes we're working not at all
for a week and they're working 20 hours
a day yeah and sleeping for two hours a
night like it doesn't make any sense to
me so is the point you're damned if you
do and damned if you don't the point is
I'm getting a new job yeah you want to
be a high-powered corporate executive I
can see myself working for a brand yeah
I somehow I find that hard to know
couldn't could what comedians do what
could we do what could you we could be
in a think tank of like advertise like
we're good with words were right like
slogans where yes all you can do
probably right yeah do you ever think
that like if we're slightly off topic
here well let's run with it that if the
world ended would there be anyone less
useful than a comedian every time I'm
watching uh walking dead and I'm
thinking these people all have certain
skills that guy with the you know the
guy can shoot a bow and never any other
they can all do things someone can you
know rig a car I'm like I really can't
do much of it I would never have another
talk about it I not much I know how to
forge through a vending machine and a
minibar so bad pretty good I would
survive yeah help feed other people
exactly no but honestly I think we're
leaders and that if we can calm
on the masses are amongst the chaos yeah
that maybe we would people wouldn't die
of fear make less of the fear right ya
feel at ease that's a great skill yeah
yeah do you guys think that maybe the
day of the celebrity sort of dropping
dead early usually because of drug use
you know there's they call it the 27
club where you've got Jimi Hendrix Janis
Joplin Jim Morrison Kurt Cobain Amy
Winehouse they all died at 27 that seems
to be phasing out a little bit i mean
Amy Winehouse was a couple years ago now
right because people are more aware and
I guess it's harder to hide all the
addictions because there's pictures of
everybody so that's kind of good right
it's the world has become CSI universe
that I mean just even from both the
Boston and then yeah they found them
because there were cameras right
somewhere so like I feel like everywhere
I go no matter what I'm doing I might be
seen and that causes you to not be a
recluse drug addict or doing nefarious
things yeah I mean miss you're careful
if you are yeah right or among dr. drew
um but yeah I think there's more of a
community watching the person
self-destruct yeah there's more of it
it's like talking about you know these
eneral is with this these young girls
that get famous fast and get out of
control cuz they don't really get to
grow up on their own they get to grow up
with everyone watching them yeah yeah
where everything you do is is on Twitter
on Facebook or on television or TMZ or
whatever it's like you don't there's no
way to be safe in that way so you have
to be a little bit more responsible for
your actions to some regard or someone's
gonna throw you in rehab instead rather
than just like put you at the chateau
marmont let you waste away yeah you
think we have any responsibility these
people like amanda Bynes is the perfect
example the girls clearly going off the
deep end right now she's heading in that
Lindsay Lohan road do we have any [ __ ]
Chris Farley Chris Chris Farley's
another one I miss that guy but yeah I
mean do we have any responsibility when
we're now watching this happen cuz I
guess that's the point social media is
changing where we're literally every day
if you want to see what amanda Bynes is
done to go down that road a little more
you can see it and one day the roads
just gonna end
we'll have all been waiting is she still
gonna do it if you don't have an
audience you're still gonna perform yeah
I mean it it's give or take a yes but I
don't I don't know are we responsible
man what can I don't know there are
things I guess you can do and you can
try and you know if you know her
personally perhaps i'm generalizing with
amanda bynes maybe step in but in the
meantime they're still adults that I'm
making adult choices whether they're
right or wrong so what do we have to do
I think dr. Phil should step in he did
um Brittany yeah please dr. Phil the
last time he stepped in i think it was
with that guy remember the golden voice
guy yes and then you know there was this
homeless guy that they found on the
street and he had this incredible
announcer's voice and dr. Phil stepped
in kind of cleaned him up two days later
the guys like he was beating his wife
again and he was like drugs but he does
have a kraft macaroni and cheese does oh
right you did you did a voice of her
mother I can say for myself yeah maybe a
crab man honey and cheese all right
let's let's move on I like this story so
gay gay gay everything each week there
is some breaking gay news and we've got
some good gay news here Nike wants to
sponsor an openly gay athlete so Rick
welts who's currently the president of
the Golden State Warriors he's openly
gay and he was the president of the
phoenix suns when he came out this is a
couple years ago and before he actually
came out he met with NBA commissioner
David Stern some executives at Nike and
the nike people told him that if an
athlete comes out they would like to
sponsor that person and now he's just
waiting for somebody to do this and I
think this brings up a lot of questions
but first seems all good right that Nike
is throwing it out there just putting it
out there before someone's even out we
want to give you money hey even if I
well if I weren't gay that didn't come
out right I don't think you are good no
but if you're in a traditional marriage
as far as I I am yeah what I'm saying is
if there's an athlete who's not gay yeah
what I read was that there's millions of
dollars for this person
so they could just fake it for oh so
you're saying they could literally be
gay for pay as a term in gay porn right
you were saying I was his bullets now
it's in sports they could be gay first
there is a straight guy out there that's
going I want some of that cash I don't
really need was just thinking how funny
that would be yeah sure you're not the
only person who's thought that there's
someone in the locker room who is
questioning that yeah I wish it were
adidas they were sponsoring it because I
prefer ideas yeah but you're also not a
professional no not anymore retired but
with Adidas as a sponsor um I I mean
it's great it's more incentive I guess
to know I guess maybe push someone out
but I don't know that that's the right
term because I don't know that that's
fair yeah it's good to know that there
are people that are willing to rally in
support but i don't know maybe that is
my point is it gonna for someone too
much too yeah the first one to sign on
the line they're adults right yeah
there's something that seems a little
bizarre about it to me to dangle the
money out there first because if nike
for example they usually take the cream
of the crop they take michael jordan and
kobe bryant and you know the best of the
best and now they're like if you're gay
right exactly you're gay you did it with
a dude like we got millions of dollars
for you but you may be scoring two
points a game it actually seems a little
a little bad i could actually see that
causing resentment against the gay
athletes is that does that make sense
yes yeah but if they had sponsored
billie jean king or Martina Navratilova
yeah instead of I guess they lost money
because they were because they were out
yeah they were out of the sport yeah
Martina had said that she lost she
thinks what could have been about 10
million dollars by being out but that
actually brings up telling which is that
for some reason we accept women as gay
athletes very easily actually just this
week the NBA draft the WNBA draft
Brittney Griner was selected number one
and came out pretty much at the same day
but Nikes not gonna throw her extra
money for being a because we kind of do
do we accept it though if Martina lost
all that money and you can see that I
mean her career suffered after that a
little bit her endorsements did do we
really accept it now we're looking for
like a male superstar in quotes to come
out and do that I think one order
already did an episode about trying to
keep the privacy of one of the gay
athletes like they were ahead of the
times yeah daddy tonight can cut that
out yeah involved though there was a
murder okay yeah maybe you're just
making up a show all together it's
really interesting because I had never
heard of this being an issue yeah um
that anybody cared but I guess it's a
big deal for a gay football player to
come out it would be a big I mean
there's been no professional athlete in
the united states that while playing in
any of the major sports has come out a
couple people have come out after but
you know this was also making making me
think that there are other businesses
still and other careers that being out
especially as a guy is not the thing to
do and one of those such careers
actually his comedy if you're if you're
a girl in comedy or a woman girl woman
lady any of those things the optic being
yeah the opposite of guy yeah you can be
gay and in a way it almost works your
advantage between Ellen and Rosie and
Wanda and there's there's a slew of
lesbian comedians but really no openly
gay guys where do you think that come
you know we're expecting an athlete to
do it who has to get naked in a locker
room well maybe the incentive is maybe
nike better step up to the plate and now
all right i want some of that cash two
questions about the first one is back to
the sports thing i wonder how much this
money is gonna motivate somebody more
than actually like doing it for I'm some
sort of reason to be a role model right
someone's throwing a hundred million
dollars at you you're gonna change your
mind a little quicker yeah would that
matter even though in the long term does
that even matter if they did it for the
money to actually were gay and came and
ended up here I don't know I mean I'm
just looking at it in a deeper way that
maybe i should but or maybe everyone
else should look that way too but i
think nike is probably going well we had
tiger woods and we had who are the two
others that were scandalous panel
armstrong right like well they didn't
turn out so great right yeah maybe yeah
we have nothing to lose yeah well and
just do it like nike just do it that
when they come out with a commercial
that's talking about being in the closet
and then coming out just do is I mean
you generate an ad campaign well you
were right from the segment before you
found you his new skill at Wendy Liebman
nike you want to get her some of that
advertising cash okay why do I want to
remind you guys that the Rubin report is
brought to you by bonobos calm my shirt
my pants my shoes are brought to you by
bonobos enter code trr 20 for twenty
percent off your first purchase and
let's get to the last story I think this
is a fitting way to end funda where
people durex is bringing us fun to wear
it allows touch to be transferred over
the internet but don't take my word for
it let's let's watch the clip
take it feels like a cutscene
okay that gives a whole new meaning to
ipod touch all right i mean what this
has been coming for a long time right
should we be surprised by oh nice that
was no it was real they are going we are
gonna be wearing electronic underwear an
electronic bras and it is gonna be
hooked up and you're gonna be skyping
with your husband or your lover or
whoever or a random stranger and they're
gonna be touching things and vibrating
how do you feel about I'm wearing them
right now actually I'm not wearing them
but I do have my cell phone in my pants
which is the old school way of doing
this yeah I mean is this is this the
future this is a future of sex right
this is it we saw this coming I think
that that girl when she was like it
feels like you're touching me I was like
she just looks annoyed like someone's
like scraping her like is there a finger
inside that underwear or a hand because
first of all this is the first January
all right you got to give it a skype
with someone I don't want them to have
clothes on isn't that kind of the point
it's a very sexy when you're like you're
wearing a sports bra thick panties yeah
not that I'd be sexting with her or
whatever but the whole thing is weird to
me you're rubbing a phone instead of how
do you touch yourself at the same time
it's just seems much more complicated oh
no you don't touch yourself there
they're controlling you right that would
be that would be a whole area you want
to assist them like if it's not enough
right what if you dial the wrong phone
number yeah there's a lot of problems
everything about that just look too
confusing an ill thought out to me right
and also what about people wearing this
just during the day get there you know
what I mean just wondering mistress
sitting at work well what are you doing
are you texting right no no I'm buzzing
hey not yourself to you I guess to me
look yeah but why let's cut out the
middle bra right to me it right it just
looked like a lot just put on a hazmat
suit and right i mean it is it for
germophobes I guess it's for German it's
for long-distance relationship no but I
think about money and you buy a plane
ticket and go and visit that long
distance but that's the thing they want
to sell this as like
you know it's bringing people closer but
again this is like our social media
which we talked about all the time on
this show like are these things actually
bringing us closer or maybe if you're in
a long distance relationship you need to
wait it out until you until you get
actually in person it's reason enough to
be like I'll come next week instead like
there's no instead I it just looks
creepy to me yeah you want this I can
tell me oh I'm not even saying it and
the research money couldn't go to
something else I don't need you to
research how to make the bra tingle yeah
put that money towards something good do
the research on how to teach you how to
touch me better right alright so that's
a that's the part i guess that instead
of dealing with like the real intimacy
issues that everybody has yeah you know
straight gay whatever that were like
jump we're just pushing everything into
the digital space and it's like so
instead of having to look someone in the
eye and have sex with them or whatever
you're doing with them well we'll skype
this we're gonna skype it where you
remove the human part well the thing the
human part is the scent and you're
losing that if you're skyping the the
relationship until they have
smell-o-vision write somebody a mask on
which is gonna be even more attract yeah
i think they had that right one day
we're just gonna be in a box and the
other person is gonna be in a box and
it's gonna be do you think gay people
are gonna get on this first cuz gays
seem to always be the early adopter no
because I think days already have their
apps that they don't need to touch each
other with they find an app they find
someone 26 feet away to come over and
touch them and then go home it's done
yeah you need and you don't have to keep
your underwear on the answer this is I
wouldn't touch it with a ten-foot pole
right I wonder how much more brazen
people will be sexually though with
things like this you know I mean you
might be willing to do things like what
though I think the direction the range
of motion just seemed very much like
this right so I don't know how risky you
can go like what if you want to like you
get this if you have an iPad you have a
bigger range of motion well maybe that
you're overweight people i don't i don't
know but i don't i just don't want
someone touching me like this yeah i
want someone with free i want a sensor
on every piece of that which means you
need a whole suit then yeah it's just a
disaster way to go you can end up you
jump in the pool with
run to right on you get electrocuted at
your battery dies and the person on the
other end doesn't someone there's call
waiting someone sends you a text and
everything fries there's a three-way how
you do a three-way how do you do a
three-way I don't even like three way
calling yeah yeah yeah all right well in
just a matter of weeks I'll be wearing
these underwear and you guys will be
able to you know to rub your dial and do
some stuff to me okay on that note let's
let's pimp you guys out and get you some
people to do stuff with your magic
underwear Paul case where can they find
you oh you can find me at at Paul case
you can find me on facebook at Paul case
um check my website okays com Wendy
where can people I'm gonna be in Boston
at the somerville theater on May
sixteenth with Jimmy tingle and John
Fugelsang it's a great benefit concert
and it's just gonna it's our sixth year
it's gonna be rockin and at Wendy
Liebman on twitter twitter all right
guys I thank you guys for watching and
we'll do this again next week all right